e aí
e a inteligência artificial é uma ameaça
ao nosso emprego
e os robôs realmente vão no substituir o
que que nós estamos falando quando nos
preocupamos a respeito do impacto de
toda essa revolução tecnológica que que
está chegando e potencializando a nossa
capacidade de produzir e resolver os
nossos problemas humanos
nós estamos acostumados a ouvir a falar
a respeito de atividades passivas
substituir na verdade o que pois é um
longo processo desde a primeira segunda
revolução industrial aquilo que é
mecânico que automático mas agora
estamos também ouvindo falar de
substituir atividades que pareciam
exigir de nós algum tipo de raciocínio
análise montar relatórios consolidar
dados
e a inteligência artificial está sendo
pintada por muitos como um verdadeiro
monstro e uma ameaça à ao nosso emprego
é mas afinal de contas a que serve a
tecnologia a tecnologia que como nós
estamos vendo ela já está presente no
nosso dia a dia seria por ter mais
repetimos alonga presença em diversas
áreas como desde assistir um filme no
netflix utilizamos carros inteligentes o
mesmo google ou nos perguntamos como é
que poderíamos dirigir em são paulo sem
ajuda do waze essa tecnologia ela já
está presente na nossa vida e está
prometendo está presente muito mais de
uma maneira muito mais intensa mas a
nossa pergunta para ela é a que serve a
tecnologia
e se pensarmos na história da humanidade
tecnologia de uma maneira muito simples
é apenas um instrumento
e desde que o homem aproximadamente 500
mil anos ele começou a produzir o fogo
desenvolveu técnicas para poder produzir
o fogo ele começou a utilizar-se de
ferramentas que começaram a transformar
a sua realidade e aqui nós temos um
aspecto extremamente importante a
mudança ela faz parte dessa realidade da
nossa experiência humana através da
história desde que começamos a utilizar
instrumentos que passaram a
potencializar as nossas funções atender
melhor as nossas necessidades e de uma
maneira cada vez mais abrangente mudança
que está aí e que na medida de que a
tecnologia avança essas mudanças nos
impulsionam mais e mais rápido
e afinal de contas se pensamos sobre
substituição podemos nos perguntar
substituição do que muitos de nós
estamos nos perguntando quem será
substituído mas o que nós podemos ver é
que na verdade nós somos um longo
processo de atualização sejam das
atividades humanas ou seja o mesmo dos
instrumentos que nós utilizamos ao longo
da história e agora de uma maneira muito
acelerada qual de nós não vai lembrar um
rápido olhar ainda do nosso processo de
transformação histórica em que começamos
a utilizar o cavalo para nos
transportarmos utilizamos charrete
utilizamos o trem carro estamos voando e
agora com carros que voam que são alto
dirigidos faz parte desse processo de
avanço de
e a substituição na busca de uma maior
eficiência de uma real efetividade e a
natural que também nos preocupamos ao
invés de quem será substituído é o que
que nós queremos deixar de fazer para
nos dedicarmos aquilo que realmente nos
interessa que nos motiva que nos realiza
e que está nem tinha idade daquilo que
nos identificam como seres humanos essa
é a nossa grande questão imaginando que
em diversos momentos deixamos por
exemplo do mundo moderno de lavar roupa
e utilizamos a máquina para que ela
liberte o nosso tempo esta é uma questão
fundamental ea revolução tecnológica nos
traz ela está nos liberando cada vez
mais maneira potencial para realizarmos
aqui
o que nós somos e aquilo que nossa
queremos ser
e logicamente temos um conflito muito
grande porque nesse processo todo de
substituição de atualização por mais
moderna que sejam as tecnologias existe
um caminho natural para o nosso
desenvolvimento não obstante nós já
temos experimentado inúmeras
transformações a algo que nós recebemos
que recebemos da natureza que está
implantado na estrutura do nosso cérebro
e que isso não foi substituído não foi
transformado em um verdadeiro tesouro
que é a nossa capacidade de aprender
talvez podemos conceituar que a
capacidade de aprender é a mais incrível
tecnologia de que fomos dotados na
evolução do nosso cérebro
é porque quando nós estamos falando de
aprendizagem humana nós estamos falando
de um conceito que se refere
essencialmente aqui aprendemos aprender
aprendemos a desaprender aprendemos
mesmo a esquecer e como importante
esquecer
e como importante para nossa saúde
mental inclusive mas não é apenas
aprender nesse conceito estrito mas é
acumularmos conhecimento aprendemos
novas coisas adquirimos novas
informações e sermos capazes de acumular
para poder gerar o progresso
é mas só seremos capazes de coletar
informações uma compreensão da realidade
sermos capazes de acumular não explica a
nossa natureza humana a um terceiro
elemento muito importante que a nossa
capacidade de transmitir de aprender com
outro efetivamente o nosso cérebro em
uma terminologia mais moderna e
atualizada nesse século que está sendo
chamado o século do cérebro nós temos o
termo cunhado de neuroplasticidade o que
nós ouvimos muitas vezes que aprender é
mudar o nosso comportamento isso é
tábula rasa aprender é mudar o nosso
comportamento mas essa mudança hoje ela
está demonstrada intimamente na própria
estrutura do nosso tecido cerebral
através das mudanças que os nossos
neurônios fazem
e está demonstrado que realmente
aprender é uma transformação física que
ocorre em nós neuroplasticidade é um
conceito neurobiológico da aprendizagem
essa alteração do nosso tecido neural
pode estar sujeito graças aos impactos
ea interação com o meio é preciso nos
recordar que o desenvolvimento do nosso
cérebro e especial a região frontal ela
se desenvolveu como um simulador de
desafios de probabilidades de soluções
esse simulador permitiu que as ideias
passasse a morrer no nosso lugar isso
foi uma estratégia revolucionária da
nossa evolução
e não é à toa que nesse momento nós
vemos que a metodologia e o avanço da
tecnologia tenta simular cada vez mais
situações próximas da realidade porque o
nosso cérebro ele se desenvolveu nas
savanas africanas nas ar na áfrica há 2
milhões de anos e há 40 mil anos o nosso
século não mudou nada mas nesse processo
de interação é que ele se desenvolveu
nesse processo de enfrentar o real é que
o cérebro se caracterizou como um grande
processador de formação e de antecipação
dos acontecimentos
e observamos que a partir de todo esse
processo histórico de transformação da
nossa capacidade de aprender hoje temos
os empresários e profissionais de
tecnologia que estão atentos a essa
necessidade de interação de troca porque
o nosso cérebro suponha essa interação
com o meio e não apenas como meio ele
supõe uma interação também com o outro
então eles se utilizam hoje que uma
metodologia conhecida o apelidada como
raton que nada mais é do que uma
maratona de programação e que se reúne
uma quantidade dezenas muitas vezes
centenas de pessoas com diferentes
especializações um diferentes
competências e experiências para poder
discutir e elaborar a partir de um
problema real
é porque afinal de contas nós somos
inteligentes mas inteligência e
inteligência qual o conceito que
poderemos utilizar aqui sem grandes
complicações inteligência é aquilo que a
gente usa quando a gente não sabe o que
fazer fomos você acordar como falamos há
pouco do nosso cérebro se desenvolveu no
período e que nós não tínhamos manual de
caça
o diariamente quanto nós a humanidade
saía para caçar ela podia ser assada
podia não voltar para casa e aprende a
se a cassar cassando então a a
inteligência que do ponto de vista
neuroevolutivo é um prolongamento da
nossa capacidade da nossa adaptação ao
meio para garantir a sobrevivência se
estruturou diante daquilo que ela
poderia perguntar e agora
é o que tem o que vem adiante então por
isso uma condição essencial um conceito
estrutural da inteligência é que ela
está preparada para poder se estruturar
para poder elaborar soluções novas
porque se nós aprendemos a dar a
resposta certa a uma pergunta certa
sinto muito isso não é inteligência do
ponto de vista técnico isso pode até ser
classificado como esperteza porque nós
treinamos a nossa mente a inteligência
ela é acionada como mecanismo diante da
realidade que o preciso inventar o
reinventar uma resposta
e no processo profundamente criativo é
natural que quando falamos sobre a
questão da tecnologia e do empregado do
futuro desafio do mercado diante de toda
essa revolução a gente ouça falar quais
são os esquilos as competências as novas
competências para que possamos
sobreviver nesse desafio nesse mercado
inovador
e a boa notícia é que como nós falamos
há 40 mil anos o nosso cérebro já não se
modifica todas as competências todas as
habilidades que nós podemos desenvolver
elas já estão potencialmente dada pela
natureza para nós
e o que nós estamos vendo que vamos
falar quais são essas referências atuais
é que elas ganharam vitrine
e agora aquilo que era considerado
genialidade de poucos está sendo
apresentada como uma identidade
essencial da nossa natureza
o que seriam essas competências tem 15
que são consideradas fundamentais
inclusive pelo fórum econômico mundial
o pensamento crítico
a criatividade comunicação
a cooperação e uma extremamente rara
curiosidade
eu penso logo existo quando renée
descartes é concluir o seu pensamento
seu processo mental de buscar
fundamentar um método de encontrar um
método que pudesse ajudar efetivamente
alcançar a verdade
a iris chegou à conclusão sobre o
pensamento mas na base do pensamento
para de kart estava a dúvida a dúvida
como metodologia olha que coisa parece
tão inovador mas já de alguns séculos e
ao mesmo tempo tão antigo e tão atual o
pensamento é o que nos identifica nessa
capacidade uma espécie transformadora e
dominadora do nosso do nosso planeta
pensar olhar a realidade perguntar
porquê
é questionar o óbvio esse essa é a base
de todo o processo transformador e
criativo dos seres humanos
a e agora o que é que vai garantir o
nosso emprego
e o que que realmente vai garantir a
cada um de nós aqui presente ea todas as
gerações futuras a uma participação
efetiva na nossa comunidade através do
trabalho
e o que é um tecnozon vamos encontrar
essa referência dentro da nossa própria
natureza encontramos no engajamento
social e incrível de um jovem que salvou
uma criança de quatro anos em paris e
condições totalmente imprevisíveis
é pensarmos em uma criança de 4 anos que
estava de pendurada na varanda do seu
apartamento no quarto andar de um prédio
é de um jovem imigrante ilegal do mali
o desempregado sofrendo uma série de
condições é águas adidas para sobreviver
e encontrar a sua identidade naquele
país vendo a reação e mesmo todo
atônitos desesperados preocupados com
aquela criança mas imobilizados pelo
inesperado ele
a escala de maneira surpreendente essa
esse prédio esses quatro andares
em uma velocidade incrível 30 segundos
sem hesitar em condições sem equipamento
de segurança sem nenhuma referência e
sem um tempo largo se não aquele desejo
e aquela vontade incrível de salvar
o miri encontramos as preferências do
que é pensar que não é apenas a lógica é
o raciocínio é a emoção ea decisão ele
identificou o problema ele buscou
energia para impulsioná-lo e tomou a
decisão por isso ele está empregado
o olhar o